this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house greetings you bad [__]
it's Monday the 21st of November the
joint is brought to you by the freeze
pipe I'm dreaming of an ice cold
Christmas a beautiful cold Thanksgiving
with freeze pipe you freeze it you pack
it up and you smoke one until you
[__] eyeball pops out
the Hot Smoke passes through the Frozen
part cooling down the smoke as you
inhale I love my little freeze pipe I
love my little bubbler I love my little
freeze pipe bung freeze pipe is
non-toxic freezes faster than water and
stays Frozen a lot longer freeze pipe
cools down the Smoke by hundreds of
degrees now freeze pipe is even better
they've updated their box so they have
six independent freezing calls for even
better airflow and much easier cleaning
experience you know what I like about
these guys they even got a 2023 Edition
every year they get better so your Uncle
Joe is taking care of you on this one go
to thefreeze pipe.com pressing code Joey
to save 10 off your first order get
yourself a new bong pipe or bubbler
today that's the freeze pipe.com
pressing code Joey to save 10 the joint
is also brought to you by CBD lion
listen these guys are the best I've been
working with these guys for years and
they never seem to [__] not impress
the [__] out of me whether it's a
kinesiology tape the cream the [__]
back walls and now they got the [__]
uh Delta a gummies listen to me you
gotta go with them and I'm gonna give
you some [__] motivation 30
30. read the third party lab results and
[__] get your life situated the
tincture is out of this [__] world
pressing code Joey joint or church and
get 35 [__] percent off at CBD lion
I'm [__] excited already let's get
this party started on a Monday [__]
morning here
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you bad [__]
it's Monday the 21st [__]
Thanksgiving week Jack it's
this is [__] real this year has uh
flown the [__] by before I even start
saying anything I wanna I don't know
what the [__] happened Sunday night in
Colorado Springs Saturday night some
[__] guy went crazy in a gay bar took
a [__] gun or whatever you know
I saw that Sunday morning when I woke up
and I gotta be honest with you guys like
as something that always bothered me was
I had to take a test in 19 like 92 like
a a parenting test
and the results came back that I had no
empathy and that always [__] bothered
the hell out of me you know like who the
[__] doesn't have empathy like I don't
know if it was a fix I don't know what
the [__] it was
but I'm the type of guy when I read
something like that no matter what it is
like the next morning whether it's
Buffalo or Uvaldi or whatever the [__]
it is you always think about those
people the next morning like
I can't imagine having a son and I get a
call at four in the morning that some
guy walked into a bar and shot him and
you got to go down there and identify
them and find out what the [__] happened
nobody's giving you answers and then on
top of that it's [__] Thanksgiving
week it's it's it's horrible you know
having to bury somebody on the Wednesday
before Thanksgiving I don't know what's
going on in the world I who the [__]
knows anymore you know we're just lucky
that uh we don't get in a situation like
that I pray for people that never
get in a situation like that and hit
home because one of the guys that comes
on the podcast one of my dear dear
friends Eric Rocha he's gay and he's
from Colorado Springs so
I called them last night I didn't get an
answer from them I just you know Hey
listen man I'm not Johnny [__]
therapist but something like that
happens it hits close to home you know
you got to reach out and say hello how
you feeling you know everybody takes
everything differently you know not that
he was going to be in Colorado Springs
he lives in L.A but that could happen
anyway you know and what kills me is
like later on that night like Sunday
night I I went out and I can't Got Back
and write something on Twitter or
something that they you know right away
this comes days after the Republicans I
mean I'm sick and tired of everything
getting politicized anymore you know
everything's got a political agenda
anymore everybody's got a conspiracy
theory yeah it's uh
it's crazy what the [__] is going out
there you know if you're uh
I don't know if you're intelligent if
you're not intelligent you got to ask
yourself what the [__] is going on from
time to time you know the damn patreon
one of my friends on patreon sent me uh
one of the guys on patreon good guys
been on there for like a year sent me a
YouTube clip and he's like have you seen
these you know
you go on there and you see uh
[__] two guys I've never even saw
before on a podcast just destroying Bert
Kreischer
like just destroying Burke Reicher but
the movie he's doing or the movie The
Trailer came out or something like that
and listen whether you like that or
[__] not I mean the movie hasn't even
come out yet and there was two kids
trash and Bert that the movie sucked
look at this look at that and I'm like
I don't even know these two guys they
had to be like 25 or whatever but just
trashing [__] Bert at his movie and
I'm like you know
I'm his friend and I didn't even call
him up and go burnt that [__] trailer
or whatever
it's just crazy I'm looking at and going
who the [__] wakes up in the morning you
wake up you [__] John leguizamo's at
War again this time with Steven Seagal
yeah and it's like guys you know all of
a sudden like [__] uh
everybody's putting out a book lately
has got to trash somebody you put out a
book this guy from friends with the
pills he's trashing [__] Keanu Reeves
the chick put out a book she's trashing
[__] this guy it's like everything
that comes out is to try somebody now it
just can't be [__] it just can't be
like a book like this is what happened
to me in my [__] story and uh
this is what I'm gonna [__] stick to
you know right away we got to go through
a dag at somebody or something listen
I'm the king of that [__] I love busting
people's balls and I love to have a good
time but I'm not gonna write a book to
dedicate it
to just throw little dicks but here's
the funny thing guys
just so you know where this comes from
when those people go in to pitch those
books
I gotta tell you this is going to make
you laugh
I had about four meetings with different
Publishers before I sold the book you
know and a lot of them were like wow we
didn't really want to talk to you
because of what happened with Rogan on
the podcast and you know the [__]
and I'm like you know wow this is uh
surreal like that's gonna [__] take
my chances of of [__] selling the
book you know but anyway I gotta be
honest with you man the bigger
publishing companies
they didn't give a [__] about my story
they really didn't they were like and
they mentioned specific [__] names
like can you tell us any dirt on this
guy you know you being in Hollywood for
23 years that's what they want they want
you know that's what they want
they'll even give you an extra [__]
hundred thousand like if you ever seen
the movie Molly's game about Molly the
the chick that was in charge with
gambling it's a [__] story it's got
to do more with Spider-Man and Leonardo
DiCaprio being part of the game but
Molly's uh whatever the [__] name of
the movie Molly's game Molly's book
whatever the [__] it is
she talks about it she goes when they
offered me the book The reason why I had
such a low
uh guarantee they call it like a deposit
whatever the [__] they really call it
was because that's what they ask you
they go are there any juicy [__]
details in there
you know we know like they even did
their work like they do you have more to
add on Whitney Houston I mean they just
had questions and I'm like no
because that's not what the book is
about the book is about a loser that was
a loser that was a loser and in some way
he got lucky and he [__] became a
comic and next thing you know he's on
stage with Joe Rogan and Bill Burr
that's what the [__] book is about
but a lot of people don't know that that
when you uh sell a book especially if
you're one of those people like a
tell-all book like if I [__] call
somebody tomorrow like a book publishing
company and I want to tell you
everything I know about this thing that
happened and I give you uh you know
they'll ask for [__] proof that you
have information and all that so your
[__] Advance is ginormous
so whenever you see these ads for people
oh Gina Davis put out a book and she's
trashing [__]
scumbag and [__] uh you know uh the
guy from Friends whatever his [__]
name is Chandler put out a book and he's
[__] you know he's blaming his
addiction on the dumbest [__] things
in the world I just I can't even read
that [__] but I know where it's coming
from so now you people know that when
that [__] goes down they gave him some
extra money he sold his [__] soul me
I didn't want to [__] sell my soul
I've sold it enough I didn't want to
start with this [__]
but that's what's [__] going on this
week man I'm excited this weekend I had
a [__] blast you know we've been all
looking I go to Jujitsu as a hobby I'm
not a [__] fighter I'm not planning
on fighting nobody I don't fly through
the air no more I don't think you know I
do the best I can guys but I go to
Jujitsu just to stay healthy it's more
of uh of a social thing for me like I go
there and see people and talk to people
my age and younger you know you wrestle
you're [__] sweaty the whole thing
but it's a hobby it's a hobby that I've
never [__] had like my hobby was
comedy that's all I [__] knew for the
last 40 years my my hobby was to watch
movies study them and then I became a
comic and I went after that so that was
my [__] Hobby
so me and my wife were talking a couple
months ago like we just need some [__]
you know we need something going on in
our life my wife went back to work last
week a couple days uh
just to do something you know there's
days my wife will say something to me
and I go that's the mind of somebody who
ain't working because if it's something
that small you wouldn't [__] worry
about it in a big [__] world you know
so uh she started working but something
else they called her from the rec center
and they asked if she wanted to coach
girls basketball
and she was like sure so she put a team
together with my daughter and some of
the girls from softball
I went to the practice last Wednesday I
did not know what to think
guys you know I'm a basketball guy
that's my world
before I became the biggest loser in the
world I love I love basketball I loved
it and then I was somebody broke me
freshman year and I never played again
it's a [__] shame you know I mean I
play pick up games as I got older and I
gambled playing basketball on myself we
hustled people but I never played uh
whatever number one that always weighed
on me that weighed on me for [__]
years that was like a uh
it was more like something that I never
wanted to do again you know and when I
quit basketball I walked away from it I
walked away from it
my uh I played my freshman year and then
by February or March I got into smoking
dope and partying big and I'm like I'm
not gonna play basketball I'm not going
to take this [__] you know either I
start well I'm not gonna [__] it I
wasn't willing to work you know and I
quit
and I walked away from it and I saw the
kids that I played with and came up with
become varsity basketball players and I
got to tell you some guys it wasn't my
mother's death at the time it wasn't
that I was confused it wasn't that I was
doing drugs I was a criminal one of the
things that weighed me down the most was
just quitting something
that has such a [__] weight on you
that
if you don't give a [__] you know and
then once you start quitting things guys
it builds a pattern for you to quit
everything
it gives you an excuse that's it I'm
quitting I'm quitting I'm quitting uh
you know you ever meet those people what
happened to your job at the oh the guy
was an [__] what happened to your job
at the window place oh they wanted me to
work nights what happened to your job at
the bartending like ah the guy wouldn't
let me [__] drink on the job do you
ever meet those people those are the
people
that always [__] quit when the going
gets tough and guys I was one of those
[__] like I said before what I
get into comedy I got the comedy because
I tried everything the [__] else I was a
cook I was a bartender I was a roofer I
[__] laid railroad ties you know how
many little jobs I walked away from
after like an hour
like the same for me there's too much
work like I'm not doing this I don't
need to do this I can sell an eight ball
that was my [__] attitude for years
and it was made to me available to me by
quitting basketball it was just
something and guys I was never a [__]
quitter it was just something I didn't
like how I was treated
I didn't like that they wanted me to
[__] work I didn't like that they
wanted me to prove myself and I was I
guess somewhere on my in my heart I
thought I was above that and I just
walked away from it
and looking back I talked about this in
the church in the very beginning
that I had quit [__] masonry I was a
roofer you know when I was a roof I was
a little old and I didn't quit my wife
dumped me so I lost my [__] family
job you know what I'm saying it's not
like I quit Roofing I would have still
been Roofing but I quit I kept quitting
[__] and it was all due to that one
basketball [__] season when I just go
that's it I'm not doing this anymore and
I tell you guys it ate a [__] away at
me and I think that's the reason why
it took me so long to get on stage
that's the reason why it took me so long
to propose to my wife
because I always wanted to make sure
you know
when I got out of prison and I got put
in the halfway house I was infatuated
with [__] Andrew Dice Clay I was
infatuated Andrew I was infatuated with
Kennison
I was infatuated with Bill Hicks I mean
I was just infatuated and I'm like the
last thing I wanted to do honest to God
was to go down to Comedy Works get on
stage and me not like it that was
[__] fearful as [__] because if you
don't think I thought about that at that
time I was [__] 25 years old I had
nothing going on for me
I was a felon and now I'm about to put
something else on my [__] shoulders
which
in my mind I thought I could never do so
part of my fear to get on stage was that
if this didn't work out I was going to
be in a tough [__] position this was
going to get tough for Uncle Joey I
would have had a [__] uh double up I
just didn't know what it was and I like
the work guys I like the [__] gift of
working hard I like outworking people I
love [__] out working people you know
I love all that [__] but it was just so
[__] difficult for me to do anything
because I was addicted to Coke and
everything
you want me to work eight hours or ten
bucks an hour and I'm gonna make eighty
dollars I can make a hundred sound an
eight ball so that was the stupid excuse
I would give to me they're [__]
legitimize why I would quit whatever the
[__] I did and guys I had opportunities
that most people would pray for
pray for I was thinking about an
opportunity I had back here in 1984.
I had worked at a lumber yard when I was
a kid and I picked up some good [__]
like I knew some [__] from that lumber
yard I mean I really [__] did it was
a part-time job for me but you know I
had nothing else going on and when I
went I mean I was going to school but
when I went into that [__] hardware
store I learned my [__] Galvanize screws
[__] door jams [__] saddles for
electricians plywood [__] marine
plywood I [__] knew it all so I got a
job at Mass back Sunny Hardwell when I
quit High School to support myself and
my stupid drug habit and after that I
[__] around for a few years I was
thinking about this job the other day I
got a job offered to me
with no high school diploma no GED at
the time I just went in there
bullshitted them and I was experienced
enough
and I got a manager's training program
Mass Back warehouse and like [__]
I like to say like East Rutherford or
something like this this was
1984. summer of 84. you wanna you wanna
kick yourself in the head you ready for
this one
it was a 40-hour week
at a desk
Uncle Joey got a desk job
as a Salesman and helping people order
like you know like just a Salesman and
then I worked all the time in the
warehouse they would let me work 20
hours a week overtime at the warehouse
like 20 bucks an hour
okay 20 bucks an hour at it's like 400
[__] bucks okay plus the [__] like
16 I was making in the daytime I still
remember not having the money to go get
a [__] dress shirt like a dress shirt
but here's what got weird
my days off were Monday and Wednesday
I like the Wednesday I like the Monday I
wasn't crazy about the Wednesday but the
opposite of that was I had to work on
Saturdays and Sundays
the first week I worked I worked you
know Tuesday I think I trained the first
week and it was [__] superb the first
week I had like a marvelous [__] week
but I worked Monday through Friday
following week I came in Tuesday
Thursday Friday and it was like July
10th or something like that and all my
friends were going down the shore on a
Saturday
and I was like come on man
so I called the guy up and I made some
excuse about Saturday morning he's like
don't worry about just coming Sunday I
got to go down the shore and come back
and jump up and down to the Quaaludes
and I went into work that Sunday and
Sunday was brutal because my friends
were going back to the shore like
Montego Bay the more Quaaludes and jump
up and down I'm like [__] this that
sadly had one in there and I was the
only salesman there on a Sunday
like uh what am I [__] doing in here
so that Monday I scrambled I went in
there Monday I'm like listen guys I came
Saturday I had a problem Sunday I came
in here and [__] uh you know it was
like a ghost the phones didn't ring
it's the summertime guys is there any
[__] way until the winter can we just
outwork the whole [__] week I work
Monday through Friday from 6 a.m to
[__] 10 at night I didn't give a [__]
at that time I just want my weekends off
what's happening you bad [__]
I'm here to talk to you about DraftKings
tonight you got Arizona playing San
Francisco over and under 43 and a half
[__] the line is I think uh eight San
Francisco's laying eight it all starts
with [__] DraftKings the best the
officials sports betting partner of the
[__] NFL new BET is BET five dollars
to win 150 in free bets and right now we
got [__] the same game parlay boost
that'll make your [__] [__] has
burned on [__] fire every leg you add
you make more [__] money it's that
simple at DraftKings and don't forget to
[__] around with their prop bets I love
their little prop bets when you download
the sports betting app look at these
little glasses that they have every
night it's like uh this guy to win this
guy to have a [__] run uh score two
touchdowns bet those you could bet ten
dollars went up to 80 90 200 DraftKings
so download the DraftKings sports
betting app right now and start today
but five dollars tonight and win 150 and
free bets when your team wins but it
starts with you download the DraftKings
Sportsbook ad use code Joey j-o-e-y only
at DraftKings code Joey minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply she
showed notes for details now back to the
[__] podcast download DraftKings
[__]
I just want my [__] Saturday off so I
can snort some coke and jump up and down
my [__] friends the guy goes listen I
love to accommodate you but these are
the rules
I guess I'll see you this weekend it all
works out brother it's a great job
Insurance [__] benefits pension I
mean [__] free insurance this is
amazing to give you free Insurance
Dental Tow Jam Insurance [__]
Insurance you had everything eyeball
insurance
and uh I worked that those three days
and that's sadly I [__] just said I'm
not doing it
I kicked myself in the ass for that job
for years and shortly after that maybe
four months after that I was [__]
homeless that was the beginning of the
homeless so how much do you think I was
kicking myself in the ass in that rocket
ship for walking away from that job
because of Saturdays because I couldn't
work Saturdays oh my God how will I get
my life together I can't work [__]
Saturdays that is the most immature
dumbest [__] thing I've ever heard in
my life but I did it I did it that's the
type of quitter I was I had
kind of those [__] jobs my buddy got
me a longshoreman book I went one time
and unloaded bananas left like in the
afternoon left I got bit by a spider or
something like that 20 bucks an hour my
other friend got me a job at APA loading
trucks I went there with a [__] eight
ball I loaded three trucks I sold the
gram and I got the [__] out of there you
gotta get some Skies this was constant I
was America's biggest [__] quitter at
every [__] level of the game it was
it was uh pathetic
but I still remember holding off holding
off
you know then I didn't quit that job in
prison that's the only job I didn't quit
I kept that job for the six seven eight
months and I was there as the [__]
warehouse supervisor driver that's the
only job I couldn't quit because if you
quit they put you in the [__] South
now for 24 hours I was like [__] it I
gotta maintain this job so when it came
to stand up comedy I was like
if I try this
and I quit with this felony I am
officially [__] done
done done
and I was like okay and I waited and I
waited and I made double [__] sure
and thank God it all [__] worked out
when I walked off that stage I was like
well when I walked up that stage I quit
but it wasn't quitting comedy was
quitting my [__] day job I'm like I
gotta get out of this [__] job now
how am I gonna [__] do comedy with
this job but
I stuck with the comedy and I stuck with
it when it was [__] the toughest
yeah when you're an apprentice you gotta
go get coffee and you gotta dig [__]
trenches and you gotta [__] pick up
trash around the job and you gotta
[__] you know when you're a prep cook
you got to cut and you and for the first
year you cut three of your [__]
fingers off you walk around like a
Yakuza you know you have to pay your
[__] debts and that's when I was
giving up I refuse to pay my [__]
debt to something
I had it just got so [__] old
it just got so [__] old I had another
job
[__] uh
shabun snow not the 13 an hour with a I
used to shovel snow for 13 bucks an hour
but it was like a hand shovel and I was
really casing out joints in snowman's
Village but
then I got a job [__] shoveling like
a little [__] truck like a little
high low and [__] they gave me like two
grand for clothes I think I bought a
t-shirt
they gave me two grand for winter
clothes like yeah like I was working in
a [__] plow they they wanted me to
get a body suit with heaters in it and
[__] they gave me two grand Advance they
take it out of your check I just went
and bought Coke and bought like a
t-shirt like the [__] thermal t-shirt
I remember going the first time the
guy's like where's your jumpsuit man
that's like a 500 jumpsuit where is it
we gave you money I'm like I lost the
check you know whatever
that job was like [__] 65 000 a year
and guys
it was the winter
the winter
that means if I would have had that job
year round I would have made a buck
[__] 30 as a loser 65 000.
in the winter
November December January February March
sixty five thousand dollars
I [__] did it one night they came to
my house they beeped the horn I was
coked up I gave him the finger out the
window that was enough of that I was a
volunteer firefighter guys over three if
I you know what that's my project for
next week it's going to be kind of quiet
I want to write jokes and [__] I'm going
to write out every [__] job I quit
and then put them posted somewhere on
Instagram you guys will [__] die and
the quality of [__] jobs that I
walked away from yeah I walked away from
a lot of like [__] you know you know
short order hamburger maker [__] that
anybody could do by flogging into a
[__] glass but guys I walked away
from jobs that most people go
Joey are you [__] kidding me not only
that I was a felon I was a [__]
Dropout I was a Coke fiend and I was
still getting these jobs would not still
find a job that I got you know how much
that's to find a job paid you
do you have any [__] idea how much
the sports betting service how much
money you make off that [__] I made
sixty thousand dollars
December of 94.
in December of 94. I did it 92.
and then they fired me at the end of 92
because I was just going in there with
tissue papers in my nose I swear to God
I would just walk in there with two
tissue papers coming out of my nose like
[__] Dracula and they would go Joey
you can't smell coconut I'm not snorting
coke I'm absorbing the coke from last
night and then I would take the tissue
out and put it in my mouth like a
[__] uh like a [__] a pouch but
you're dipping your [__] in your
mouth it's just guys craziness
but it was all attributed to me letting
my like okay
I just [__] quit and I'm with comedy
guys
I had to think about this before I told
you
I probably quit comedy
50 times the first two years
because it's always like I just bombed
a whole week straight
never mind bombing one show in front of
people that's okay you can live with
that
how do you take a week-long bomb like
think of getting on stage Monday night
bombing Tuesday night bombing Wednesday
night bombing Thursday night bombing
maybe one joke worked you had bright one
bright spot you [__] uh made a stupid
improvised joke and one of your jokes
made people giggle some stupid joke you
wrote Friday night Bomb by [__]
Saturday you're like crying to yourself
if I don't get a lap tonight I'm done
I'm [__] quitting this [__] that
would be me on the Coke and on the
[__] alcohol the night before I can't
take these bombs anymore I gotta do
something I would [__] sit there with
the Judy Carter book them [__] fat
tire and [__] cocaine and I try to
write [__] Joe was terrible but the
whole night I'd be [__] I'm quitting
I'm quitting after tonight I don't need
this [__] I'd start looking at the jobs
in bold and then [__] the next day
I'm like what am I getting up on stage
tonight thank God I am so [__] happy
that I didn't let my [__] ass [__] take
over the [__] but it all goes back to
and I always say this guys
best day of my life was the day my
mother died because it toughened me the
[__] up to no end I went from [__]
Zero to Hero not that I had done
anything but I understood what life was
you know when you're a kid you walk
around like what's rent you know what's
it what's the gas bill what's you know
Mom can I buy that sweatshirt not even
thinking it's twenty dollars when your
[__] parents dying you're alone in
this [__] world you learned [__]
quick I was like okay this [__] is
[__] quick now but I had that little
pussyism from having a Latino mom that
you know oh it's gonna work out your
next game no there ain't no [__] next
game [__] it's this game where I should
have [__] done what I was supposed to
and that's what the problem is that
those lenient moms it's like oh he did
okay no he [__] didn't he squatting
the opposing [__] basket that's not
okay you know what I'm saying you got to
work with that [__] [__] he can't
be doing [__] like that
and uh that was my thing my mother had
me [__] soft as [__]
so when I quit when she was alive I
didn't tell like did you play bad like
oh I was always getting tortured for
playing basketball my black people would
come out hey you can't dribble the ball
at six in the morning you know all this
[__] I'm like now you're [__] happy
I'm not playing no more [__] but
I think quitting is [__] one of the
worst habits you could get yourself
involved in one of the worst one of the
[__] worst because you'll quit
everything you'll quit relationships it
makes you quit jobs it makes you quit
opportunities you'll quit bands you quit
everything you don't have the ability to
sit there and go okay this is what needs
to be done and I have this time listen
guys that's maturity that's [__]
maturity it's like I always say when
you're 20 years old when you're 18 years
old and you're graduating college high
school and somebody comes to you and
says join the service you can retire in
20 years you're like [__] that 20 years
is too long 20 years ain't [__]
20 years ain't [__] think about if
you're 18 years old and you're [__]
getting out of the army at 38 five six
thousand dollar a month pension college
education and you go get another [__]
job now and keep your [__] pension so
even if you make four grand the month
with the five you're getting from the
government you're not [__] you're
[__] you ain't missing any goddamn
meals you know you're really not missing
no [__] meal so
it's uh you can't look at things like
that it's like comedy when I tell people
and this I read it all the time people
send me emails you're wrong comedy
doesn't take that long it just took you
that long because you're a loser okay
okay uh whatever I'm I've seen it I've
been a part of it I I see people who are
stuck to five or six because here's the
other thing with comedy why you don't
want to quit and why you don't want to
quit anything okay because when you
start doing slowly listen what do you
think when I go to Jujitsu I'm down
there sweeping people and submitting
people
the [__] time I don't know what I'm
doing and there's tons days that I say
to myself you know what
I'm talking about to be 60 why am I here
why am I here and I won't let myself
quit even if I just go in there and make
it through the [__] warm-ups I will
not make my let myself quit because it's
something you cannot do you have to
stick with it it's like people who quit
diets how many diets did I [__] quit
over the years you talk [__] on a Sunday
this week I'm gonna eat salads and then
the [__] Tuesday morning you're
eating an ice cream bar at eight in the
morning
you know with Weight Watchers I stuck it
up
but that all went back to him stand up
comedy and learning that 10 years is not
a long time
think about it
think about if I said to you you could
have this in 10 years
these are the things you could have in
10 years if you stay healthy you're not
going to be a millionaire
but you're going to have security you're
going to be able to pay your rent you
could be able to take your girlfriend on
a trip anytime she wants to [__] go
you know
that's what gets my dick hard is that
I don't want to be rich but I want to I
don't want to go [__] I wish I had money
for a [__] hot dog I did enough of
that over the [__] years where you
wished you had money for anything
so it's just uh don't let yourself quit
at any [__] level guys I mean it
ruined my [__] life but
10 years you know and even after the
[__] stand-up comedy I think I did
some uh creepy things like just day jobs
that I didn't show up to or construction
jobs that I ended up just robbing a
hammer and quitting and I was you know
it snowed here on the East Coast this
weekend uh but it snowed up in 77 inches
up and whatever
and it's been cold it's been really
[__] freezing the last couple days
here in Jersey
and a couple nights ago I had to take a
ride somewhere and I had to drop some
off of my friend's mailbox
and I pulled up and there was no
parkings and I went over to [__] I
went over a thing of leaves you know and
I thought about Tony Soprano when his
[__] son when the [__] car blew up
or whatever the Nissan truck the utility
vehicle blew up because you have a
catalytic converter over uh
a bunch of leaves and I was laughing I
was laughing about the scams I was doing
when I first got into comedy like
not when I first got into common like
from 94 to 95 and a half
I uh it was the big Latin boom in Denver
so all the car dealers were looking for
uh Latin salesman you know Spanish
salesman
and I had you know I had a pretty good
reputation
selling cars in Boulder and whatnot
so I had a like a pseudo cousin who told
a bunch of people in Denver about him
this kid speak Spanish he's Cuban he's a
comedian so he could do your advertisers
you're not going to believe this [__]
story
so for about from I I wish I was kidding
you guys from the time I landed
in Denver
which is October of 93 November of 93.
to uh June of 95.
I had no money for a car
I used to bomb the car from the uh
from the deli they had a delivery car
that used to have what do you call those
things that pulls and it has a hook at
the end to seal it down like if you you
put a TV in the a bungee cord that's how
you close my door with a [__] bungee
cord okay if you made a [__] sharp
left the door opened up a sharp right
the door opened up I got all those
stories for you [__] okay I
don't want you to think that you know
there was a Mercedes Benz one
so I went back there and I'm [__]
driving this car and [__] like that
I don't even know oh and my cousin said
to me you know these people Douglas
Toyota uh Rocky Mountain Nissan John
Elway and let me tell you something I
picked them all apart
every month every six every [__] 10
weeks I'd be in a new dealership and
this is my deal five thousand five
hundred dollar draw
a new car the drive
and the commercials I have to shoot
commercials for like uh you know Latin I
love to find those [__] commercials
that I did they are
god-awful but the first one I did them
for was Douglas Toyota so
you would shoot these stupid commercials
hello me I'm lost Antonio again
you know the whole [__] deal
and then people come in and ask for you
holy [__] guys as I [__] making money
but I would take these comedy gigs and
then I would have to go to the people
and go hey I gotta do this gig I gotta
leave you can't leave if you leave
you're fired done right there when they
say you're fine I go okay and I get on
the phone right there at that dealership
when I call the other dealership and go
high do you need a Latin Department yes
we do who am I speaking with Joey Diaz
I'll be there tomorrow morning I would
go over there for [__] a month and I
would ask him for two draws and [__] to
give me a call guys I did this
every other month some guy gave me a
thousand dollars some guy gave me 1500
to start you know I get an advance at
the videos it was
this is [__] being an open micro Guy
this is what you need to do when you pay
your bills and [__] and they kept
putting it but the night that I still
die about was I went to work for a dear
friend of mine a friend of mine called
me in uh Elway Ville he lived out in uh
maybe Lakewood that was the name of it
Lakewood Jeep Eagle
it was one of those uh Bob the guy owned
like 20 [__] dealerships in Colorado
and my friend Jim handy the same guy who
talked me into comedy I got to give him
a [__] call reached out to me he goes
hey I'm over here running this thing
come on and I go Jim that's all the way
out in Lakewood I need a [__] car he
goes come just come pick whatever
[__] car you want so I went out there
the first day I took one of those jeeps
and [__] you know those nice four-door
Jeeps nice [__] pieces of [__] the
door would fall off I remember one day I
was selling one of those things in New
York and the passenger was in the
driver's side and I went to get out and
guys I was 185 pounds at the time
1990 yeah 1993 I was probably 215 and
I'll never forget that I grabbed on the
thing to get out of the car and the
whole ceiling [__] came down the car
I was like holy [__] I'm not selling
this car but this is this is the best
ever so I go to work with my friend
Jimmy and I have a I'm working for this
guy named Bill Bauer Bill Bowe was a
solid [__] Booker he owned a
motorcycle shop and uh in uh Fort
Collins maybe or one of those uh Greely
rebooked this part-time gig he wasn't a
comic his part-time gig was booking
these shows in Wyoming and [__]
hell places places where you never even
dream of going but he would find the
barn and pack it up and when I tell you
they were barns guys it was like you
could smell the chickens and [__] but he
paid he paid and it was State time who
the [__] am I to but one of my best
nights ever
I went up there to the gig and they're
talking snow and [__] like that it was
one of those
Mitsubishi had the eclipse
so Jeep Eagle had the matching car only
with an American name so whatever
Mitsubishi was selling with the eclipse
these guys had whatever and I took a
brand new one off the [__] floor and
I took it up there I think I was meeting
some girl and I wanted to impress her
some [__]
and not two minutes when I get to this
[__] gig in Wyoming
I see a [__] snowflake like this big
like one of those big [__] just
lands like I could see it all the way
down I'm like that's a big ass snowflake
and once it touched my glass like a
thousand of those [__] were
everywhere and I went in I think I was
I'm seeing so I had a do my 15 bring up
the Rick cards and then bring up I
forget who the headliner was
and that night they were like guys just
coming down if you guys want to spend
the night here it was one of those two
foot of Snows in Wyoming they [__] comes
down down there and I'll never forget
getting in that [__] car
and flying down the I-70 or whatever the
[__] I was
and at one point I couldn't see because
there was so much snow and I pulled over
and I I'll never forget this I pulled
over but I could see there was a gas
station there and I'm like
maybe I'll go over there and get
something to eat and stop but I go I
need to stop over here because I
couldn't [__] see anymore the the
snow was coming down at a high rate
and all of a sudden
I smell [__] smoke
right now I'm just sitting there the car
is on I'm just relaxing
I smell [__] smoke
I'm like where the [__] is this smoke
coming from it's a brand new car it's a
brand new [__] car why should this
car be smoking
I swear to God I get out of the [__]
car
and I can hear like crumpling paper like
when paper is burning there was a fire
under the [__] Hood guys and I'm
talking about it reminded me of trains
planes and Automobiles and it was one of
those type of nights only with heavier
[__] snow
by God guys I don't know if we get
looking at the car and it started
burning and burning and then fire was
coming out of the hood and [__] the car
was still running I just happened to go
in there and get my [__] bag out of
there I sat there for about 15 minutes
like a [__] snowman while that car
just burned and burned I didn't know if
it was going to blow up or not like I'm
not going to be here for when it [__]
blows I walked that [__] half a mile
to that gas station I went in there and
guys I looked over like an hour later
and that car was on fire and [__]
fire trucks over there I'm like holy
[__] how am I gonna get home so I paid's
one of the guys and he's like we're just
leaving now we'll pick you up what
happened to your car I go you'll see
when you get me at the gas station and
that was the end of that I guess I had
to quit that [__] job there was no
chance of coming back I had a call I had
I just called Jim on Monday and go your
car's in Wyoming get it towed what
happened to it it lit up on fire I don't
know what happened he called me a few
days later he wasn't mad at me it was
like the timing chain
or some [__] that happened yeah so
but that's where we're at today talk
suckers it's Thanksgiving week
and uh I don't want to take up all your
time you know I don't do a [__] hour
no more if I got 40 minutes to talk I
talk for 40 minutes if I got 20 minutes
I talk for 20 minutes and we got two
hours we'll talk for [__] two hours I
like these Monday short ones just to
give me the train of thought of what I'm
thinking about you get it and you
[__] move on with your [__] life
the key word today is not to quit dick
guys it's not good for you
it creates bad [__] habits and he'll
follow you listen I quit at 16 and it
followed me to [__] 28 28 was when I
quit doing [__] uh when I quit
quitting things that were good for me
don't quit don't ever quit anything
stick with it you know
stick with it
just stick with it guys I [__]
struggled a lot with comedy guys and my
feelings are hurt a lot along the way
and there was many days where I was like
I'm gonna get a [__] day job but then
I would go if I quit that's going to put
me back in the level I was 10 years ago
that's going to put me back on a
different level I'm going to keep doing
this whether it's success whether it's
TV or whether it's just having a job the
next 30 Years that was my [__] goal
and that's how you have to look at it
and look at it for success I didn't look
at it did you see Dave Grohl in the
Hollywood [__] thing playing with uh
the guy from The Commodores they would
grow has to stay home he's got to start
staying home start staying home
[__] anyway that's it and that's
that I love you [__] with all
my heart I will see you Wednesday
morning Tip Top Magoo so you have
something to go on Thanksgiving have a
great day uh stay black I love you and
now for a word for my [__]
sponsors Jack all right I want to thank
you guys today to putting up with my
[__] just remember don't quit but before
I go I want to shout out my sponsors
first off CBD lion that's got a Black
Friday sale
35 off you heard me right 35
[__] percent off that's how we
roll at CBD lion whether it's attention
the back ball the kinesiology tape the
Delta eight the gummies everything they
got I liked so go to cbdlion.com
prestonco Joey joint or church and get
you a 35 off let me tell you something
those Delta a gummies are a [__]
steal for 35 off the joint is also
brought to you by the freeze pipe listen
we're all dreaming of a nice [__]
cold Christmas this is the time of the
year you lay a bong on somebody but not
just any bunk the freeze pipe this is a
[__] bong you freeze it you pack it
up and you smoke some reefer until you
see [__] Jesus the Hot Smoke passes
through the Frozen part cooling down the
smoke as you inhale who's better than
you nobody I love my [__]
bubbler I fill that [__] thing up I
take that chamber out of the freezer and
I knock myself into Gaga Google land
freeze pipe cools down the Smoke by
hundreds of degrees so it won't burn
your throat and the new freeze pipe is
even better for 2023 they've updated
that Bond so you have six independent
freezing calls for even better airflow
and much easier cleaning experience your
uncle Joey's taking K is to go to the
freeze pipe pressing code Joey to save
10 off your first order that's get
yourself a new bong pipe a bubbler
that's the t-h-e freezepipe.com pressing
code Joey the joint is also brought to
you by the [__] DraftKings listen you
dirtbags it starts tonight DraftKings
the official sports betting part of the
NFL is Uncle Joey's go-to when betting
the NFL this holiday season or tonight
Monday night we got some great games
tonight we got some great Dallas Cowboys
on [__] Dallas against the
whatever the [__] whatever the [__]
they're playing on Thanksgiving Day you
got Buffalo listen right now everybody
can step up earn 100 boost with
DraftKings stepped up same game parlays
go to draftkingsports book download it
and place the same game parlay and
combine multiple bets like which team
will win player props which are the best
on DraftKings and point totals but it
starts with you download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now use code Joey plays
Five Dollar Bet on any NFL team to win
that game and get a hundred and free
bets when they do it's that easy only at
DraftKings Sportsbook with code Joey
j-o-e-y minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details I want to thank the freeze pipe
DraftKings and Black Friday CBD line 35
off I want to thank you [__] Savages
and I'll see you Wednesday morning Tip
Top Magoo stay black and I love you
[Music]